we are in a sacred space
we are in a lush natural environment
we are in the kind of environment that
evokes
aesthetic appreciation right we are
beholding
beauty and beauty demands a response
so at first we marvel
we admire
we take photographs
we experience the radiance
the lushness the suchness of the natural
world
but what then
well you hope that what follows this
appreciation is the urge to protect
to protect
and
steward
this space
to make sure that we do not take for
granted
the beauty
the fragility
the utter miraculousness
of these ecosystems of these landscapes
of this natural environment the whole
move towards eco-conservation is
i think akin to a kind of
personality change or a or a response to
a religious experience right a come to
jesus moment of sorts where we awaken
to symbiosis we awaken to
the systems nested within systems we
awaken to
biological evolution we awaken to
ecodelic consciousness we awaken to an
appreciation that we are nested within
larger
holes
and
this is kind of like a psychedelic
experience a mystical experience a
spiritual experience there's a guy
called tim
duty who said moments like this move us
past our egoic shell they move us past
our self-concern
we
re-contextualize right re-pattern
re-contextualize the notions of a self
and we see ourself instead expanded we
see ourself redefined we see ourself
instead as a marvelous
conduit of sorts in a timeless
larger whole from which molecules and
meanings flow from neurons to nebula and
back again like the powers of ten film
from the micro to the macro and beyond
time from the geologic you know and the
prehistoric and you know and and so all
of a sudden this this
recontextualization and this reframing
and this beholding of oneself as a
conduit in a larger hole from which
molecules and meanings flow is to bask
in the mystery is to bask in the
mysterium tremendous otto rank in his
book the idea of the holy wrote about
the nature of these religious
experiences and these encounters with
the mystery that repels and the mystery
that attracts with a kind of sublime
encounter with ineffability with
something vaster than we are but
something also far more beautiful and
benign and benevolent and omnipotent and
so these these dances with starlight
these moments of beholding this larger
vastness this moment of
reconciliation and reinterpretation of
one of what we are
is a kind of enlightenment right we
undergo an enlightenment and an
expansion once the
the idea of what we are dies the the
birth of what we really are comes into
awareness he who must save his life must
first lose it and and i guess we could
only hope that more people have these
experiences beholding nature
in a deep enough way that a shift
transpires that rewires their nervous
system reframes their perspectives
re-channels what they see revivifies who
they think they are and then in turn
changes their actions in the world may
we all rise together into the light and
steward our environment protect our
environment marvel at our environment
worship our environment and truly come
back into the garden of eden
and
that's the kind of ecodelic
consciousness that i'm interested in may
we all wake ourselves up
and then steward ourselves and this
planet back into the light for we are
starlight right like our atoms were
cooked in the furnaces of stars and so
the idea of us
coming to see ourselves in this way
seeing ourselves as self-organizing
assemblages of atoms cooked in the dying
stars and getting to participate in an
evolutionary process of such
unfathomable complexity this
teleological self-organizing
self-writing self-authoring songstress
you know this this theater this this
carnival of like engendering complexity
that mutates and explodes in every
direction this intelligence explosion
this creative explosion this explosion
of complexity in every direction we can
participate in it as we behold it and as
we watch it we can be in the thralls of
it while we are stewards of it all at
the same time we are way for the cosmos
to know itself and we are a way for this
we are a way to sing the songs that
orchestrate the universe and to that end
that's our responsibility to be the
mouthpieces and the stewards of this of
this realization this revelation you
know this this singularity
and uh
it's a lot of beauty to fathom it's a
it's a lot of beauty to fathom but
that's our responsibility that's what
we're here to do to be these marvelous
conduits
these marvelous conduits in a timeless
hole
and what a dance right to to just grab
our seat for the game of the millennium
man what a gift what a gift what a gift
what a gift what a gift